Now, maybe you don't believe me, maybe you don't believe that
special relativity could possibly be for real.
Clock's disagreeing with each other--what's going on, how do we test it.
Well, as a matter of fact, we're actually testing special relativity right now,
and we're doing that with a series of GPS satellites which are constantly in orbit over earth.
The way these satellites can localized someone's position on earth so precisely involves
precised measurements of distance between each satellite and the observers' GPS device.
This precised distance measurements actually require a precised time measurements,
but these satellites are moving relative to the earth, relative to the observer.
In fact, they're traveling at about 14,000 km/h.
Can you tell me what β is associated with 14,000 km/h--
a.k.a. what fraction of the speed of light is this.
Enter your answer in scientific notation.
I've put the 10 in here for you and you can put the exponent in here and the rest can go right here.